bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va pas
les de camus et de l'absurde après mon
épisode sur sartre vous avez été encore
plus nombreux que par le passé à me
demander de parler de son meilleur
ennemi génome m albert camus pourquoi
meilleur ennemi parce qu'au départ
sartre et camus sont amis ils se
rencontrent pour la première fois en
1943 et partagent un certain nombre
d'idées notamment sur le plan politique
ce sont deux hommes de gauche qui ont en
commun un certain attachement à la
justice sociale mais sartre et camus
n'incarne pas la même gauche
camus se méfie des idéologies au général
de tous ceux qui détournent de l'humain
et notamment il exprime son opposition
au totalitarisme soviétique et au goulag
pour camus on doit dénoncer les goulags
comme on a dénoncé les camps de
concentration pour sartre au contraire
on doit maintenir un soutien à l'urss
pour des raison d'alliances et de
fraternité politique
il se trouve que sartre était communiste
et qu'il avait encore des gages à donner
au parti communiste qui le considéraient
comme un penseur trop pessimiste
l'amitié entre les deux hommes sera
consommé suite à la publication par
camus de l'homme révolté en 1951 dans
lequel camus critique violemment
l'existentialisme et sartre lui répondra
tout aussi violemment dans un article
des temps modernes en 1952
mais si j'évoque ce lien d'amitié et la
rupture de ce lien d'amitié entre camus
et sartre c'est surtout pour illustrer
leurs divergences philosophiques une
divergence qu'on a parfois tendance à
sous-estimer
d'ailleurs il n'est pas rare qu'on range
camus dans les penseurs de
l'existentialisme ou quand sartre dans
les penseurs de l'absurde
en réalité s'il y a un penseur de
l'absurde en france au 20ème siècle
c'est camus et même si on trouvera des
points d'accord entre leur philosophie
respectives
sartre et camus ne partagent pas la même
vision du monde ni de l'homme camus
penseurs de l'absurde qui nous a livré
sa conception sur ce sujet à travers
trois oeuvres et on notera d'ailleurs
que ces oeuvres appartiennent toutes à
des gens littéraire différents
le mythe de sisyphe à l'essai l'étranger
un roman et caligula une pièce de
théâtre je pense
ce choix
camus d'avoir mis en forme sa pensée sur
l'absurde à travers non seulement le
prisme de la philosophie mais aussi
celui de la littérature est un choix qui
est en lui-même porteur de sens porteur
de sens sur la manière dont on peut
rendre compte de l'absurde
j'oserais dire sous toutes ses facettes
voilà pourquoi dans cet épisode je ne
séparait pas les écrits philosophiques
de camus de son oeuvre littéraire sur la
question de l'absurde et je pense même
qu en procédant ainsi vous saisirez
mieux toute la profondeur mais aussi le
caractère extrêmement concret de la
pensée de camus sur l'absurde
en un mot le but de cet épisode
ce sera de vous montrer du moins je
l'espère à quel point la philosophie de
l'absurde camus peut entrer en résonance
avec les questionnements existentiels de
ce que orwell appelé l'homme ordinaire
alors comme point de départ de notre
réflexion d'aujourd'hui je partirai de
la toute première phrase du mythe de
sisyphe qui résume parfaitement le
problème
et qui dit il n'y a qu'un problème
philosophique vraiment sérieux c'est le
suicide jugé que la vie vaut ou ne vaut
pas la peine d'être vécue c'est répondre
à la question fondamentale de la
philosophie
alors pourquoi je
tant que cette phrase résume tout le
problème de l'absurde et bien c'est
parce qu'elle exprime parfaitement la
radicalité la brutalité au sens d'une
pierre brute et le caractère extrêmement
concret de ce que camus considère être
l'absurdité de l'existence
parce que s'il est vrai que l'existence
est absurde
alors surgit aussitôt à question
corollaire à quoi bon vivre
si le monde est absurde si la condition
humaine est absurde alors l'option du
suicide comme solutions pratiques à ce
problème ne peut être contournée à moins
de considérer que nos convictions
philosophiques ne soit que de la
décoration intérieure
et si le thème
soulève d'autant plus cette question des
conséquences pratiques de notre
philosophie c'est parce que l'absurde
touche à la vérité première de notre
existence
l'absurde ce n'est pas juste un système
de pensée l'absurde
ça touche à la racine de notre condition
ça touche aux profondeurs de notre être
et faire de l'absurde une simple
abstraction dont on pourrait parler sans
que cela ne met littéralement nos vies
en jeu en faire une simple posture
intellectuelle ou esthétique pour se
donner l'air plus intelligent ça ne
marche pas l'absurde c'est sérieux
l'absurde c'est une expérience dont on
ne revient pas inchangé
andy si camus pose d'emblée la question
du suicide avant même d'avoir défini
l'absurde
avant même d'avoir expliqué en quoi
l'existence était absurde c'est parce
qu'il veut montrer qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre ce qu'est l'absurde
si on en a pas un tant soit peu éprouvé
la puissance on peut pas comprendre
l'intensité de cette question si on n'a
pas fait l'expérience dans sa chair de
ce que signifierait pour nous le fait de
savoir que l'existence est absurde
en résumé se posait la question de
l'absurde c'est se poser la question de
la valeur de sa vie
la valeur de la vie d'où vient-elle
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on accorde de la
valeur à notre existence
on avait vu dans l'épisode sur la mort
chez epicure que la mort est souvent
perçu comme un événement dramatique
en tout cas comme un événement
malheureux et douloureux la question qui
se pose c'est pourquoi pourquoi
nous autant d'importance à la vie à
cette question on peut répondre de deux
manières la première est bon
c'est d'ordre culturel nous accordons
une valeur à la vie parce que nos
religions parce que nos systèmes moreau
puis juridiques font de la vie et en
particulier de la vie humaine
quelque chose de sacré le caractère
sacré de la vie
c'est ce qui fait que nous pouvons
cohabiter c'est ce qui fait que celui
qui va enfreindre l'interdît du meurtre
l'un des 10 commandements tu ne tueras
point va être mis au ban de la société
qu'on se situe du côté de la religion ou
du côté d'une morale laïque
la vie humaine est sacrée la vie humaine
est un absolu
et même si cette absolue est de l'ordre
de l'inexplicable ou de l'irrationnel le
fait est que nous partageons pour la
grande majorité cette conception d'une
vie humaine sacré mais il ya une
deuxième réponse au fait de savoir
pourquoi nous accordons autant de valeur
à la vie une réponse bêtement biologique
mais les réponses les plus bêtes sont
souvent les moins fausse c'est le fait
que tout être vivant est programmé pour
tendre à sa survie en d'autres termes
nous considérons la vie comme sacrée
parce que nous y sommes viscéralement
attaché d'ailleurs camus à une phrase
pour exprimer cet attachement à la vie
il écrit le corps recule devant
l'anéantissement
c'est finalement la meilleure image que
l'on puisse donner de notre instinct de
survie
le recul devant l'anéantissement
est ce qu'on a
elle l'instinct de conservation qu'on
observe aussi bien chez l'homme que chez
les animaux
c'est cette concertation du corps humain
vers un but ultime qui est la
perpétuation la perpétuation
soit ce que schopenhauer appelé le
vouloir vivre et qui porte tout corps
vivant à vouloir survivre en permanence
à soi et donc fini
on rejoint un peu l'idée de nietzsche
qui disait que l'homme considèrent comme
sacré ce qui sert ses intérêts ses
intérêts vitaux
car s'il est vrai que nous sommes
programmés pour la survie s'il est vrai
que la vie cours indéfiniment après sa
propre perpétuation et bien il n'est pas
illogique que l'homme est fabriqué des
systèmes moreau qui convergent avec ceux
vouloir vivre
et quand spinoza dit qu on juge une
chose bonne parce qu'on l'a désir et non
pas l'un vers ce il dit exactement la
même chose
il dit que nos concepts sont déterminés
par nos affects et que nos valeurs ne
sont que la traduction culturelle de nos
intérêt biologique
en somme la valeur de la vie c'est le
coup de tampon métaphysique apposé sur
notre attachement viscéral et
irrationnelle à la vie alors ici ont
tous
la première manifestation de l'absurde
dans notre existence l'impossibilité
d'établir rationnellement la valeur de
la vie parce qu on aura beau dire que la
vie a une valeur parce que nous sommes
programmés pour y être attaché
ça ne résout pas le problème pourquoi
sommes nous attacher on ne résout pas un
problème en disant c'est comme ça on ne
résout pas le problème de la valeur de
la vie en dix ans on tient la vie donc
la vie à une valeur la raison a besoin
de comprendre pas de se soumettre à
l'incompréhensible la raison veut des
réponses et c'est pourquoi camus
considère que les différentes réponses
apportées dans l'histoire à la question
du sens de la vie ne sont selon lui que
des dérobades des dérobades parce que
c'est réponse saute par dessus la raison
et ce faisant elles n'ont plus de
comptes à lui rendre
la froid est un saut par dessus la
raison parce que la foi vient donner la
réponse que la raison ne peut pas donner
mais sans que la raison ne puisse la
vérifier et ça pour camus c'est trop
facile
c'est trop facile parce que c'est éviter
la confrontation éviter la confrontation
à l'absurdité radical freud dirais que
c'est justement pour éviter la
confrontation à cette absurdité que les
religions sont nécessaires parce qu'elle
permet à l'homme de fabriquer des
réponses à ces questions les plus
fondamentales dans l'avenir d'une
illusion
freud explique bien que les religions
ont été créées par les hommes parce que
c'était le moyen pour eux d'obtenir des
réponses à des énigmes fondamentale
l'énigme de la création de l'univers
l'énigme de la vie après la mort
l'énigme de la justice dans l'au delà
en créant dieu les hommes ont créé un
moyen de se rassurer ils ont créé un
moyen de supporter la vie sur terre et
leur foi permet ainsi de combattre leur
sentiment d'absurdité une certaine
hier si la fois n'existait pas
l'humanité sombrerait dans la folie
parce que la foi ça donne du sens si
pascal a fait le pari de l'existante
dieu c'est bien parce qu'il avait
conscience qu aux yeux de la raison la
foi ne pouvait être qu'un pari et ce
pari de l'existence de dieu l'homme
absurde ne le fait pas car l'homme
absurde ne cherche pas d'échappatoire
le mahb sur ne recherche pas une
métaphysique de la consolation ils ne
cherchent pas à apaiser son angoisse il
cherche la vérité fondamentale
il cherche la lucidité et c'est parce
que la vérité est une question beaucoup
trop sérieuse qu'on peut pas la déléguée
à des fantasmes ou à des scénarios
hypothétiques l'homme absurde c'est
celui qui ne veut pas comprendre par
procuration la question du sens
l'existence ne serait pas un problème
pour l'homme si on pouvait retirer de
données de l'équation
la première donnée c'est que l'homme est
un être conscient la deuxième donnée
c'est que l'homme est un être mortelle
conscience et mortalité sont les deux
ingrédients de base de la conception
absurde de l'existence humaine et c'est
ce sur quoi nous allons maintenant nous
pencher
l'homme est un être conscient autrement
dit l'homme est un être capable de
percevoir le monde qui l'entourent
capable de se percevoir comme existant
dans le monde est capable de
s'interroger sur le sens de son
existence dans le monde
dans le mythe de sisyphe camus écrit
l'absurde naît de cette confrontation
entre l'appel humain et le silence
déraisonnable du monde l'a pas l'humain
c'est l'appel lancé au monde par l'homme
pour tenter d'obtenir des réponses des
réponses sur le
sens de son existence et ce besoin
réponse ce besoin d'anéantir l'ignorance
et de transformer l'inconnu en connu
c'est le résultat direct de notre
conscience sans conscience pas de
questionnements pas de réflexion
sens de l'être et donc pas de remise en
cause de la valeur de notre existence
si les animaux
bien moins malheureux que nous c'est
parce que leur rapport au monde n'est
pas altérée n'est pas télescoper par la
conscience de leur existence
les animaux n'ont pas conscience de
suivre un chemin qui aboutit à la mort
la mort n'est pas pour eux un objet de
conscience elle est donc pas un objet
d'angoise et lorsque l'animal se
dans une situation où sa vie est mise en
danger un danger immédiat
l'animal n'a pas le temps d'éprouver
l'angoissé existentielle sa peur est une
réaction mécanique automatique dont le
but est de le faire réagir pour éviter
la mort dans une situation de danger
imminent de stress intense
c'est l'adrénaline qui nous domine pas
l' angoisse l'angoissé le fruit de la
conscience donc d'une certaine manière
la conscience
c'est le début des problèmes a
conscience c'est ce qui fait de l'homme
quelqu'un qui ne se contente pas d'être
mais qui veut savoir pourquoi il est le
fait que l'homme soit un être conscient
rend son existence beaucoup plus
précaire est beaucoup plus inconfortable
que s'il était dépourvu de cette
conscience la conscience nous fait nous
poser des questions qui n'entreraient
même pas en ligne de compte si nous
étions des animaux et la phrase heureux
les simples d'esprit illustre
parfaitement cette facilité d'être con
les personnes qui ne se posent pas de
questions inutiles sur le sens de leur
existence facilité d'être con les
personnes qui ne se posent pas de
questions contre difficulté d'être voir
douleur d'être des personnes qui veulent
des réponses la conscience humaine
c'est l'origine de notre angoisse face à
l'absence de réponse
mais l'appel
1 c'est en même temps l'appel à l'aide
l'appel au secours
l'appel au secours de celui qui se sait
condamné à mort mais qui ignore de quoi
il est accusé
parce qu'autant l'homme vit dans
l'ignorance des raisons de son existence
autant la mort ajoute à cette existence
une absurdité qui dépasse toutes les
ignorances et pourquoi la mort hante l
existence absurde parce que la mort
c'est ce qui rend tout ce que nous
faisons inutile parce que la mort
détruites ou parce que la mort
notre existence le champ de
l'impermanence et parce que là mais
spirituellement câblé pour rechercher la
permanence à quoi bon exister si c'est
pour que le temps nous efface la raison
s'accorde mal de l'impermanence la
raison
je l'unité elle recherche la fixité elle
rhj
l'éternité et ce beau
que william james appelez notre
tempérament idéaliste et directement
contrarié par l'inéluctabilité de la
mort absurde c'est ce qui n'est de notre
espoir contrarier d'éternité regard des
autres
et observer ces gens qui vivent comme
s'ils n'allaient pas mourir
nous vivons
non pas mourir nous vivons
si aujourd'hui allait se répéter
indéfiniment comme si demain ne portait
pas le poid d'hier nous vivons
si nous n'allions pas mourir parce que
l'idée de la mort est un coup de canif
dans notre contrat métaphysique idéal
nous vivons
si nous n'allions pas mourir nous
oublions que nous allons mourir parce
que cette idée nous condamne à l'avance
elle nous condamne à voir l'absurde
en face et le divertissement pascalien
le besoin de détourner les yeux de notre
condition mortelle
c'est une des solutions de survie pour
l'être humain on se donne des choses à
faire des tâches à accomplir s'occupe
comme on
tant que ça nous permet de détourner le
regard de l'absurdité fondamental de
notre existence tard quand on affronte
l'absurde contre ont fait un pas de côté
pour constaté l'inutilité radical et
l'absence de sens de tout ce que nous
faisons
le risque est grand de sombrer dans la
folie
l'absence de sens
ce n'est pas seulement un problème pour
l'être humain
un problème qu'il serait capable de
gérer comme on dit l'absence de sens
c'est l'amputation d'une de nos
aspirations essentielles et c'est
pourquoi je disais que tous les
problèmes disparaîtrait si nous n'avions
pas de conscience sans conscience pas de
questionnement sur le sens sans con
chance à l'absurdité l'absurde est un
problème humain c'est le problème humain
qu'en championnat
le principe de l'existence est absurde
quand ils réalisent que quels que soient
les efforts déployés par notre raison
nous sommes fondamentalement incapable
d'accéder au sens il préconise à
l'humanité de cesser de se reproduire
il préconise à l'humanité de se suicider
collectivement
cette préconisation est l'expression
d'un désespoir le désespoir de celui qui
avait placé dans le monde des attentes
auxquelles le monde n'a pas daigné
répondre
depuis l'aube de l'humanité
les hommes ont projeté sur les
phénomènes incompréhensible qui se
présentaient à eux des explications des
explications permettant de colmater
l'absurdité partout où elle apparaissait
c'étaient les religions qui avait en
charge la signification des phénomènes
aujourd'hui c'est la science mais dans
tous les
1 ce qui est à l'oeuvre c'est un
1 deux sens et ce besoin
va au-delà de la simple recherche de
causes au phénomène observable le besoin
de sens c'est plus qu'une liste de lois
physiques et de mécanisme de
transformation biologique le besoin
ce c'est un an
ciel le besoin d'eux
ce n'est pas de savoir le comment le
besoin de sens c'est de savoir le
pourquoi et entendait bien que le
pourquoi peut également se lire comme le
pourquoi
en d'autres termes trouver le pourquoi
ces trouvait la finalité c'est trouver
la destination
c'est ça le besoin de sens trouvez la
finalité qui donne une raison d'être
savoir que
résultat d'une combinaison de cellules
donc à héberger accidentellement une
propriété qu'on appelle la conscience ça
ne satisfait pas notre besoin de sens
voilà pourquoi
dire que l'absurde ce n'est pas le
constat d'une absence de cause c'est le
constat d'une absence de raison d'être
très différents une raison d'être c'est
plus qu'une cause il cause c'est
accidentel
il cause c'est impersonnel une cause ne
donne pas de valeur seule une raison
d'être donne une valeur et c'est
pourquoi la religion a eu historiquement
autant de pouvoir et qu'elle a exercé au
temps de domination sur les consciences
parce que la religion ne proposait pas
seulement une cause elle proposait une
raison d'être si dieu nous aime ce n'est
pas
chose que si dieu nous a créés par ce
qu'il a fait tomber deux éprouvette par
terre si dieu nous promet la vie
éternelle dans l'au delà
si la ce projet là pour nous c'était pas
pareil que si dieu nous fait courir
indéfiniment sur un tapis roulant dans 5
à notre existence a un sens dans l'autre
elle est absurde dieu c'était
précisément ce qui permettait d'abreuver
le puits des consciences en ce sens de
leur donner leur dose de sens si on veut
déroulait la métaphore de marx sur
l'opium du peuple
et si on veut comprendre ce qui fait que
la religion a historiquement autant
peser sur nos consciences et rappelons
qu'aujourd'hui encore l'athéisme reste
minoritaire dans le monde
ce serait une erreur de ne pas prendre
en compte le besoin humain de sens qui
conditionne la structure même de notre
rapport à l'existence et quand la
religion a commencé à se faire doubler
par les apports de la science en la
science a commencé à produire des
explications sur l'univers qui n'avait
pas été prévu par la religion au point
d'être devenu une nouvelle autorité en
matière de réponse aux interrogations
humaine un problème s'est posé un
problème de taille c'est classe
ne donne pas de raison d'être à notre
existence
la science
et comment nous sommes apparus sur terre
par quel mécanisme biophysique la vie à
émerger la science peut donner des
causes à notre existence mais la science
ne s'occupe pas de savoir s'il y a une
raison derrière tout ça la science ne
travaille pas sur le pourquoi elle
travaille sur le comment et comme elle
exclut de sa méthodologie même le
recours à des explications finalistes
c'est à dire à des explications qui
suppose l'idée d'une volonté à l'oeuvre
derrière les phénomènes elle se trouve
fondamentalement incapable de répondre à
la question du sens elle en est
incapable
parce que ça n'entre pas dans son cahier
des charges c'est pas son boulot
la science n'a pas vous
à répondre à la question métaphysique
pourquoi y at il quelque chose plutôt
que rien parce que si elle voulait
répondre à cette question sont pourquoi
se transformerait aussitôt en commun si
les anciens ont inventé le mot de
métaphysique pour distinguer l'étude des
choses visibles de l'étude des choses
invisibles
c'était déjà une manière d'avertir d'une
différence de nature entre physique et
métaphysique et donc privé de réponse
par la science et refusant le saut dans
la fois l'homme chute dans l'absurde est
lâché
l'homme dans l'absurde c'est la chute
originelle c'est la chute d'adam et eve
qui vivaient en harmonie avec l'éternel
dans le jardin d'éden qui vivait
littéralement sans se poser de question
pour qui l'existence allait de soi et
qui du jour au lendemain se retrouvèrent
plonger dans le monde de la matière et
du temps dans lequel il dû retravailler
et souffrir pour survivre un monde dans
lequel
aimanté la mort et la reproduction comme
unique moyen de perpétuation dans le
temps l'homme travaillait souffre en
chassant la nourriture la femme
travaillait souffre en accouchant de la
progéniture et le cycle des générations
se perpétue ainsi entre travail
souffrance est mort l'absurde c'est
quand l'existence devient la répétition
d'un cycle une répétition indéfinie qui
finit par nous faire oublier le pourquoi
de tout ceci
on a tous déjà éprouvée cette impression
de répétition cyclique
cette impression
d'éternel recommencement qui ne rime à
rien c'est ça au fond qui définit
l'absurdité l'éternel
la répétition des mêmes actions la
révolution des planètes
le site
génération nous habitons un monde
cyclique
un monde où tout ce qui est fait sera
défait c'est ça qui illustre le mythe de
sisyphe thoune et kate
elle répétition sisyphe condamné à faire
rouler un rocher au sommet d'une
montagne et à le voir retomber au pied
de la montagne indéfiniment c'est une
sion de l'absurde nous sommes tous
décisifs qui s'ignorent décisif qui font
rouler leurs rochers jusqu'au sommet de
la montagne pour finalement voir le
rocher redescendre avant de se dire à
quoi bon telle est la question
mais face à nous l'absurdité de la
condition humaine à quoi bon dans
l'étranger camus
en présence d'un personnage morceau qui
mène son existence comme si elle n'avait
pas de sens et qu'il accepte pour ce
qu'ils ont
salut l'étranger c'est l'histoire d'un
homme qui n'a justement pas d'histoire
on ne sait pas grand chose de lui
ni ce qu'il a vécu ni ce qu'il a
ressenti en réaction à ce qu'il a vécu
et un jour alors qu'il marchait sur une
plage cet homme sans histoire va abattre
un autre homme de cinq balles dans le
corps
et si ce roman est d'une grande richesse
pour éclairer la question de l'absurde
chez camille c'est parce qu'il fait de
meursault un personnage philosophique
autant qu'un personnage littéraire lab
sur deux ce sont par exemple les deux
première phrase du roman
aujourd'hui maman est morte ou peut-être
fière je ne sais pas l'absurde c'est ce
qui transparaît
si comme une indifférence à un événement
supposé provoqué l'effondrement
2 c'est le souci que porte morceaux à
des détails pratiques de son existence
sans jamais avoir l'air de se préoccuper
des choses supposé essentiel de la vie
tout ça le laisse de marbre tout ça le
laissent insensible
meursault insensible leurs sauts détaché
du monde et des grandes questions
existentielles détacher les grandes
questions existentielles comme s'il
savait déjà que ces questions ne
pourrait le mener au désespoir
meursault n'est pas le personnage du
désespoir leur souhait le personnage de
l'absence d'espoir ce qui anime morceaux
ce n'est pas une vague mélancolie
provoquée par la subite prise de
conscience que l'existence est absurde
perso c'est celui qui a acté que
l'existence était absurde et face
auditer radical me reçoit fait le choix
de continuer à vivre de faire de
l'absurdité le moyen de sa liberté
parce que si le monde est absurde je
n'ai pas à jouer le jeu de la comédie
sociale
si le monde est absurde je n'ai pas à
faire semblant je n'ai pas à ma tâche et
je n'ai qu'à épouse et l'absurdité
schneck
que tout ça ici
thil détaché du monde étranger au monde
meursault est un
sur deux incompris un homme qui ayant
compris que l'existence est absurde se
voit accusé de ne pas jouer le jeu de la
comédie sociale
perso c'est un personnage par exemple
qui lorsque sa fiancée lui dit qu'elle
aimerait se marier avec lui lui répond
si tu veux parce que pourquoi être
romantique pour quoi faire
ça avait une importance quand fondra
allemand on sait bien que tout ça est
absurde donc il ya chez meursault une
forme de transparence spontanée de
lucidité pure qui lui fait restituer les
éléments de son expérience sans les
filtrer morceau c'est celui qui ne se
pose pas la question pourquoi c'est
celui qui a remplacé le pourquoi par le
comment et qui préfère
et de ses horaires de bus et de
l'endroit où il a mangé le midi que de
ses sentiments ou de ses aspirations
profondes et c'est cette insensibilité
sat étrangeté au monde qui se retournera
contre lui lors de son procès pour
meurtre
quand le procureur rappellera au jury
que morceau n'avais pas pleuré à
l'enterrement de sa mère le crime
so c'est son insensibilité et son
insensibilité ne peut que le mener à
l'exclusion du cercle de l'humanité qui
considère que quand notre mère meurt on
doit pleurer et son pleure pas c'est
qu'on est inhumain son pleure pas c'est
qu'on les pousse pas les principes
sociaux et moraux d'une vie humaine
ayant de la valeur ne pas pleurer c'est
mettre en pratique le fait que la vie
n'a pas de valeur ne pas pleurer c'est
avoir déjà compris que le monde est
absurde et que de cette conscience de
l'absurdité la seule
id et l'indifférence d'un différend
ans coupable dans un monde
i par la croyance en la valeur de la vie
par un monde littéralement inconscient
un monde qui vous fera payer le prix de
votre blasphème si vous ne vous
conformez pas à l'impératif de
sensibilité l'homme absurde c'est
l'homme sans espoir c'est l'homme qui
n'est même plus déçu par son espoir de
trouver un sens la différence entre
l'absence d'espoir et le désespoir est
facile à établir le désespoir c'est la
réaction à une attente déçue l'absence
d'espoir c'est l'absence d'attentes rien
attendre
2 ces leçons
cheminement philosophique cohérent pour
l'homme absurde et cette absence
d'attentes n'est pas du tout de l'ordre
du ressentiment comme on dit qu'on
n'attend plus rien de quelqu'un qui nous
a déçus non là on parle d'une absence
d'attentes tout à fait neutre du point
de vue émotionnel et ça peut pas
très étrange d'associer conscience de
l'absurde et neutralité émotionnel parce
que dans notre esprit conscience de
l'absurde ne peut rimer avec pessimisme
championnat
semblait avoir montré que la conscience
de l'absurdité du monde ne pouvait
conduire qu'au désespoir ou au suicide
qu'ils soient physiques ou symboliques
et bien morceau prouve que ce n'est pas
le cas lorsqu'il
un destin tragique pour pouvoir vivre
l'absurde jusqu'au bout jusqu'au fait de
mourir pour un crime sans motif à la
question de savoir pourquoi il avait
tiré cinq balles de revolver sur cet
homme meursault répondra c'est à cause
du soleil dans la
meurtre le soleil
un rôle quasi divin le soleil prend le
contrôle de meursault et l'utilisent
comme son arme
on retrouve cette idée dans les
tragédies grecques
l'intervention divine qui scelle le
destin du héros
le destin est tragique parce que quoi
qu'on fasse pour l'éviter il s'arrange
toujours pour que notre évitement soit
en fait un raccourci le principe du
destin c'est qu'il nous emporte
bon gré mal gré hélas le destin
porter meursault
dans les confins de l'absurde perso
autre qui le dépasse lui même totalement
morceau qui
se rapprocher du monde devenir plus
présent au monde
à mesure que se rapproche sa
condamnation à mort morceau que le
destin avait prévu de rendre lucide sur
l'absurdité de l'existence et qui
finalement se réconcilier avec
l'existence au moment même où il va en
être séparé l'idée de camus est incarnée
par
so c'est que l'on peut accepter
vivre dans un monde absurde c'est que
l'on peut
si nu et à vouloir vivre dans un monde
absurde
les pessimistes sont des idéalistes déçu
les désespérés
les poètes qui avait placé dans le monde
des attentes de satisfaction et
d'harmonie que le monde ne leur a jamais
promis le monde ne leur avaient rien
promis mais enfin avant d'être jetés sur
terre l'homme a connu le jardin d'éden
l'être humain a passé neuf mois de son
existence dans un paradis perdu dans une
communion totale avec l'être le ventre
maternel étant le lieu par excellence où
aucune question n'a lieu d'être
le monde n'est pas absurde quand ils ne
nous offre pas la possibilité de voir ce
qui cloche
or dans le
entre maternelle rien ne cloche les
besoins
c'est la dualité est inexistante tout va
bien
c'est au moment de la chute dans le
monde que tout ne va pas bien
la plongée dans le
2 c'est la première expérience de
l'absurdité on est apparu sans rien
demander
on a connu le jardin d'éden pendant neuf
mois ce qui à notre échelle pour à peu
près l'éternité et on nous a jetés dans
un monde agressif sans qu'on ait fait
quoi que ce soit pourquoi pourquoi
quitter un monde
bien pour se retrouver dans un monde où
tout va mal c'est ça que j'irais le
nouveau né s'ils en avaient la capacité
pourquoi il est significatif
if que la première phrase de l'état
j'ai nous informe de la mort de la mère
du héros de la perte de l'origine de la
perte du ja
den le paradis
du c'est ça qui rend l'existence absurde
elle est là l'absurdité originel et 7
originel vaut bien qu'on moque quelques
conventions
elle vaut bien
permettent un peu d'indifférence et un
peu de
volt la révolte c'est la réponse
né par camus au problème de l'absurde
l'homme absurde
s'il devient l'homme lucide acceptera
l'absurde car il y trouvera la source de
sa véritable liberté la révolte c'est la
présence vive et profonde à notre
destinée fut à l'absurde l'homme absolue
2 et celui
se sépare pas du temps écrit camus il
voulait dire par là que le temps n'était
pas condamné à être notre ennemi et que
le meilleur moyen de le combattre
c'était de l'épouser à chaque fois
vous épousez le temps vous vous
réconcilier avec l'absurde
à chaque fois que vous êtes absurdement
absorbé par quelque chose à chaque fois
que vous créez au point d'oublier le
temps vous en lasser l'absurde sisyphe
d'abord désespérée de son sort modifié à
un jour la perception qu'il avait de sa
condition il ne se vit alors plus comme
l'esclave des dieux et du temps il se
vit mme comme une force de réalisation
comme une force d'accomplissement de son
destin il se trouve à une raison
d'exister incarné
c'est un carnet
am qu'aucune absurdité ne saurait
atteindre c1
et l'engagement passionné de soin à
chaque fois que vous incarnez
chaque fois que
vous perforé l'absurde par votre
redressement par votre affirmation par
votre puissance d'accomplissement vous
existez vous existez dans la joie il
faut
heureux je vous remercie
[Musique]